hey guys it's Greg here with a lovely
talented Oh do I see it Julie thought
Julie's on friend from Switzerland she's
visiting born and raised so it's really
not a from Switzerland a better better
so she's gonna go watch fences tomorrow
with Denzel Washington there Viola Davis
gonna be there too yeah they're my
homies yeah she just kicks it with them
smoked salmon blunt and [ __ ] awesome
yeah so for this movie did you smoke
weed at all about directing this film
anyway so fence is directed by him as
well this is a play of Viola Davis and
him did on stage together that there's
now a movie and you haven't seen the
trailers right I've not seen any of the
trailers I've only seen a clip of the
actual play from some interview with
Viola Davis cuz she's one of my acting
heroes let's watch his fencing official
trailer - I don't wanna marry I just
want to be your man Rose told me I told
him if he wasn't a man kind and move out
the way so the man kind of fun
[Music]
we're Cory I want him to help me with
this fence yup we couldn't buy a college
football team it ain't gonna get of
nowhere if he'd be like you in the
sports he gonna be all right
hey but two men ever played baseball
good as you and would it ever get me I
ain't got a pot to piss in or a window
to throw it out of hey pop can I ask you
a question how come you never liked me
what law is there say I got to like you
a man is supposed to take care of his
family
you live in my house fill your belly
with my food put your behind on my bed
because you're my son
now don't you go through life worrying
about whether somebody like you or not
you best be making sure they're doing
right by you I want him to get his far
way for my life as he possibly can get
it only decent thing about nummy Rose
who you want Troy that's all you got to
measure yourself against the world out
man
[Music]
why you ought to know is kinda what you
ever give me your feet bones that
pumping heart you've never done nothing
behold me back afraid I was gonna be
better than you
everything that I do he do for you
it's not easy for me to admit that I've
been standing in the same place
[Music]
[Music]
some people build fences to keep people
out and other people build fences to
keep people in Wow happening
Viola Davis oh gosh you got nipple
chills oh well that happens should we
check no that was amazing that was
amazing yeah I remember the clip of
Viola Davis is part Medusa you think I
have missed an with you and I got just
mad shows cuz that that is the epitome
of acting that's what my life's work is
trying right there I mean I think it's
better than the first show I saw it
Jason Horton remember him Jason Horton I
watch that trailer together and they
made ends a lot to be a much meaner guy
really I thought it was mean in this one
you see he's got a heart though you know
but you can tell there's some blockage
going on that's causing him to be an
[ __ ] to his son there's some ego
going on us causing to be a dick the
first trailer just has that one
monologue he saying like to the
somewhere he's like how do you like you
good it's just that whole monologue over
like a series of clips you're just like
a monster but the one thing out of that
monologue that I do agree with is don't
worry about who likes you or not I don't
be nice if your dad likes you you gotta
like yourself you know who doesn't like
me my downstairs neighbors they love to
only play music when I'm filming hours
can go by without me ever ever filming
days sometimes but they only cue that
music for everyone how I'm filming they
know you're like if there's talking
going around this part of the ceiling of
our apartment there is a film going on
anyway yeah but that trailer denzel's
directing skills look [ __ ] awesome I
love I love the play vibe he's keeping
with it well that's true I thought that
super expression it it's like it's like
they're all doing a play yeah where
you're performing to a crowd of people
and I feel that like whoa this is like
Denzel with real raw
tick and eaten not that he's like not
authentic every one of the best actors
ever yeah just to see like that level of
expression I feel like we haven't seen
that level of Denzel he's usually like
cool guy in films now there's like a
cool cat together
action hero yeah yeah but this is like a
full-on dramatic expression and her five
days when she's crying all it's not
tears it's not that's the real Oscar
winner bait right there the snot or they
just add snot or no that's real that is
real yeah dude I I'm gonna be curious to
see you tomorrow
maybe he'll ask this question if Denzel
shot it sort of in a way that's like a
play where it's let's do this entire
scene from beginning to end
yeah multiple cameras just get them yeah
yeah yeah like let's just take it from
this part like I'm gonna imagine they
shot the whole thing like a play yeah oh
that's a smart question really clever
question thanks to go from doing on play
and then bring that level of darkness
into it's just like wow how do you keep
replicating that because they do a plate
got it several times in two takes you
got to do that several times
oh yeah sometimes 13 takes sometimes 70
tapes that you're just breaking down and
crying that's a testament to a
phenomenal actor to be able to give
yourself so vulnerably over and over an
absolutely again and you can't think
about okay I got a cry now because that
is known as killer crying I would be so
amazed if this movie wasn't amazing you
know like if people just walked if
people watch out saying it was good I
think people would be disappointed I
feel like people expect this to be
amazing and something tells me it's
gonna live up to being amazing I think
also established Denzel
he's directed stuff before but this I
feel like will be the first this
monumental one the one where people will
go did you see defenses directed by
Denzel I feel like it's gonna be this
one anyway gents and ladies and boys and
girls and shemales and whales if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe
today
Julie's on shut up and dance is her
YouTube channel a lot of fun stuff on
there I never mentioned that in the
videos that we did before what's the fun
stuff on there Julie tell them all the
things
and dance videos music promote your show
surprises be surprised I'll go on my
channel you never know what you're gonna
get on Instagram Twitter dance juju
dance got some good pictures on there
and I'm gonna yeah that's my line
[Music]
just go just go go